la parole à notre collègue michel
vaspart pour le groupe l'est républicain
non monsieur le président à ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
malheureusement absent hier encore un
jeune agriculteur de 39 ans de mon
département s'est donné la mort parce
qu'il ne savait pas comment s'en sortir
un collectif de 300 élus toutes
sensibilités confondues vient de se
mettre en place dans les côtes d'armor
pour soutenir notre agriculture
le premier ministre impute cette crise à
l'europe certes l'europe une très lourde
responsabilité
mais monsieur le ministre qui est chargé
de défendre des intérêts de notre
agriculture à bruxelles
c'est la responsabilité du président de
la république et du chef du gouvernement
que de faire entendre la voix de la
france pour défendre avec force les
intérêts de nos agriculteurs en
renvoyant la responsabilité à la
commission européenne le gouvernement à
adresser un très mauvais message aux
agriculteurs la crise n'est plus son
problème c'est le problème de l'europe
mais quand on aura perdu entre 10 et 30%
nos producteurs
ce sera le problème de qui monsieur le
ministre d'abord celui des agriculteurs
et de leurs familles qui sont dans une
grande désespérance mais bien sûr aussi
le problème de la france
le sénat a préparé dès l'été 2015 dans
un contexte d'extrême tension déjà une
proposition de loi votée à une large
majorité
cette ppl avait le mérite d'avoir le
soutien de la profession
pourquoi le gouvernement et votre
majorité à l'assemblée nationale ne
l'ont ils pas soutenu pourquoi l'avez
vous traiter avec mépris et désinvolture
pour vous répondre la parole est au
secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement
jean marc une voix merci monsieur le
président je n'ai pas besoin de revenir
vers vous pour vous expliquer pourquoi
stéphane le foll n'est pas là mais par
contre je vais vous rappeler que c'est
votre majorité qui a fait en sorte de
supprimer les quotas qui a fait la loi
lme et qui lorsqu'il fallait aider les
agriculteurs
donnez moi du tiers de ce que nous
donnons aujourd'hui alors les leçons
s'il vous plaît je crois que vous pouvez
les garder parce que si nous sommes
aujourd'hui devant des problèmes
structurels en matière d'agriculture
c'est bien parce que vous avez d
organiser la filière agricole depuis des
années alors nous intervenons dans
l'urgence et nous intervenons aussi à
bruxelles oui à bruxelles parce que les
quotas
vous les avez laissé se défaire et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut des régulations
oui à la oui sûrement mais il faut
écouter vous êtes tellement nombreux
vous bien je regarde tout le monde vient
pour le lait la france plaidera donc
pour un roulement un relèvement des prix
d'intervention publique et la mise en
place d'un mécanisme de régulation des
volumes produits
il faudra aussi mobilisé la commission
européenne pour obtenir de la russie la
levée de l'embargo sanitaires sur le
port vous y contribuerait la
prolongation aussi des mesures de
stockage privé pour le port doit être
mise en place
il faut que nous obtenions aussi
évidemment dans le cadre de la grande
distribution des éléments de
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure ni s'agissant
des coopératives ni s'agissant de la
grande distribution enfin pour ce qui
concerne l'étiquetage de l'origine dans
les plats transformer un sujet important
pour que le consommateur puisse se
mobiliser à son tour un projet de décret
en conseil d'état sera présenté dans les
prochains jours et notifiée à la
commission européenne il prévoit
l'étiquetage obligatoire de l'origine
des viandes et du lait dans les produits
transformés
ainsi le ministre la culture associe
l'ensemble des professionnels à sa
démarche je vous remercie
tu veux ce par monsieur le ministre nous
vous avons démontré hier en votant la
reconduction de l'état d'urgence que
nous avons dépassé nos sensibilités
politiques lorsque l'essentiel est en
jeu pour notre agriculture
l'essentiel est en jeu malheureusement
vous démontrez que vous êtes en
permanence dans la politique
politicienne en ne soutenant pas nos
propositions à un moment où en france
tout part à vau l'eau nous constatons
infliger la capacité du président de la
république et de gouvernement à résoudre
des problèmes de notre pays